hard to overstate the threat of that
storm surge which everyone that we've
talked to talks about in that storm
surge is going to affect the entire
bottom half circle of Florida here that
is southeast Florida we are Southwest
Florida where it should be more
significant as well Floridians who were
trying to evacuate are running into some
serious issues here on the road block
which is a scarcity of gasoline many of
the state's biggest cities from Miami to
Tallahassee are running on empty right
now with nearly one third of gas
stations in metropolitan areas out of
gas David beg no is at a service station
in Pompano Beach David good morning to
you
Jeff good morning so we're along the two
evacuation routes headed north to
Orlando we're along the Florida Turnpike
right so going through the central
portion of the state this is the Pompano
Beach service Plaza there are 32 pumps
not as busy as it was yesterday but
they're still pulling in this morning
and you've got the Florida Highway
Patrol that's directing vehicles in
that's the turnpike and I don't see a
car on it right now there's a few coming
traffic is very light this morning
here's the good news I just talked to a
Florida Highway patrolman who said both
routes North to Orlando are wide open 95
and the Florida Turnpike and if you're
on the Turnpike we're told there is
gasoline at every service station from
South Florida all the way to Orlando
with Irma steaming ahead a steady stream
of cars rolled into this 32 pump service
plazas that have fill up while they
still can
Christine Diaz has been through this
before
I made it but the island was pretty
she plan to stay home in Key West until
a five o'clock advisory showed the
category 5 storm headed right her way
gas stations like this are becoming a
rare commodity Florida Governor Rick
Scott is pleading with station owners to
act more like public service
we need just stay open as long as you
can so people can get as much fuel and
get out we will arrange police escorts
for your employees so they can get out
safely the governor is offering escorts
because this is what the highway looked
like on Friday while this was the Fort
Lauderdale Hollywood International
Airport by night the last flight out of
town was long gone for those stuck on
the ground like Dana Sappington and her
husband Larry a small victory the last
drops from this South Miami Beach Texaco
even with police escorts helping fuel
tankers reach gas part stations many
were still on the hunt there may be an
app for that
but for Judy hide it wasn't enough we've
talked to several families who are
evacuating from the Key West area one of
the was sleeping in their vehicle this
morning they're heading north to Orlando
just got another update from the Highway
Patrol we're being told there is no
traffic if you're going from the South
southern tip of Florida north to Orlando
and there are no lines at gas pumps
that's what the Highway Patrol is
reporting this morning but I got to tell
you Jeff it is really quiet around here
folks are either gone or they're at home
they've closed the door and they're
hunkering down
David thank you